president-elect joe biden is turning to
three more obama white house veterans to
serve in his administration
the transition team says more
announcements are coming between now and
christmas even though the fate of which
party controls the senate
won't be known until two runoff races
are held in georgia next month
also new details are emerging on the
origin of the federal investigation
into the tax returns of the
president-elect's son hunter biden
and o'keefe is covering the
president-elect in wilmington delaware
this morning ed good morning to you
good morning jeff no new announcements
expected today and the president-elect
is about halfway through announcing
his cabinet several factors at play age
gender race
professional experience but there seems
to be one common theme with many of the
picks
they're familiar faces around washington
these are all friends i'm not used to
them standing for me president-elect joe
biden's cabinet has some fresh faces but
unlike the so-called team of rivals
assembled by his former boss president
obama
many of the new president's top choices
make up a team of repeats
they bring deep experience and bold new
thinking
above all they know how government
should and
can work for all americans if mr biden's
14 cabinet picks thus far are confirmed
they'd represent the most diverse
collection of men and women to ever
advise a president
today he added susan rice to serve as
domestic policy chief
she was mr obama's national security
advisor
and once had a west wing office next
door to mr biden
in the 21st century our foreign
economic and domestic imperatives
are deeply intertwined down the hall sat
white house chief of staff dennis
mcdonough chosen today to run the
department of veterans affairs
he'll be just the second non-veteran to
lead the va which includes one of the
largest health care systems in the world
and then there's tom vilsack who spent
eight years as the obama agriculture
secretary
and has been asked to come back it's
been two days since mr biden's son
hunter said he's under fbi investigation
for tax fraud
today the president-elect was asked
whether his son committed a crime
but the president-elect ignored
questions about when he learned that his
son was under investigation and he also
wouldn't say when he'll be vaccinated
against the covet-19 vaccine
more cabinet announcements are expected
next week all right
all right ed thank you